hey guys this is Pete peppers with candy
crush soda saga tips calm and this is a
candy crush soda 4:35 walkthrough with
commentary to give you some tips on how
to play this level so this is a it's a
it's a pain in the butt level but it's
one of those levels where once you
figure out the trick it's not so hard
so I made this video yesterday and I'm
going to add some play now I'll tell you
what I was thinking as I was going
through one thing to keep in mind that I
noticed after playing it a bunch of
times was it's always best to get rid of
these little licorice links first and
one of the reasons for that is whenever
you make fish they go after the links
instead of the honey so I try to knock
those out as quickly as possible just
straightforward gameplay there as you
can see the board is really tight while
they're there so you have to just go off
what you can and then let me pause for
one second the the trick here is that
the huh we got a spread jam there's no
jam on the main board so up at the top
we have four squares that are covered
with the light honey they have fish
underneath and they have the jam so you
know we're gonna try to make vertical
stripes like I just did and hit them to
get them cleared out there's also a
bunch of striped candies under the honey
so you know we're also looking to
utilize those you know here we can match
the purple that gets us ready to take
off one more layer and then we'll have
two striped candies next to each other
below
and we'll be able to fire those off so
you can see the jam at the top now and
so now I can just match the two fish
together and that'll bring some jam on
to the bottom that's the first obstacle
you have to get through but you sit
still can be tough even whenever that
happens we have about 20 moves left
there so that's a pretty good start but
we still need to try and take our time
and make good choices and right there
I'll pause it again right there's
another thing is that you want to spread
out the jam to the edges as much as you
can and then like you can see where when
we match those stripes at the bottom it
sent it all the way around the bottom
third of the board so that's one thing
to keep in mind combos will be good but
as you can see we have all the colors
out except for the dark blue and purple
so we don't have the 7th and 8th colors
so with six colors there aren't a whole
lot of chances for big combos with
different specials so just take your
time like I am right here and if you're
patient you'll get some things to happen
there I just went ahead and used the the
color bomb because I could get most of
the board opened up and now we just need
to get these last two the spots covered
up and that'll be that and you know it's
not always that easy but it is kind of
the level that it's frustrating but at
the same time you can't you know you're
in the beginning just work on getting
that Jam spread down to the bottom board
and then
they're just take your time and be
meticulous and spreading it out and like
I said it you won't always get it
complete but the better and faster you
get that you get rid of the licorice
links and then get the Jam to spread
sooner or later you'll get past it so I
hope this helps I hope you'll like the
video if you found it helpful
you know subscribe to our channel so
that you'll know when we make new ones
and if you have any questions leave
comments below I'll be making more
videos soon so I'll see you then